national insurance is going up today um
put that to the health secretary he says
there's no alternative i disagree when
people are facing huge rises and their
energy bills foo bills cost of filling
the car
this is just the wrong time for the
conservatives to be adding all these
unfair tax rises remember it's not just
the nash insurance tax rise they've
frozen the income tax allowance during
bringing lots of low paid people into
tax for the first time this is just the
wrong timing when people are struggling
so much that's why liberal democrats are
arguing for an emergency tax cut we
think vat should come down to 17 and a
half percent that would give people on
average 600 pounds a year in
less vat that's the sort of bold measure
that's needed given these difficult
times how do you make that calculation
well um first of all it's going to cost
about 18 billion so it's quite a big
measure but if you look at the fine
print of the the budget statement um
they're dragging in 40 billion pounds in
extra vat because of inflation because
prices are going up the chancellor gets
gets extra money from vat so i i think
the least he could do
is use this sort of tax cut that liberal
democrats are putting forward to help
people okay um you say that
the average family uh will pay an extra
430 pounds in vat compared to last year
how do you make that calculation well if
you look at the amount of money that
they were predicting uh a year ago from
vat the receipts into the exchequer
because uh inflation's gone up so much
and is predicted to go up much the
government is now forecasting the
independent office of budget
responsibilities now forecasting they'll
rake in
38.2 billion pounds extra over this
parliament that's a huge amount of extra
tax and if you break that down on a
yearly basis for every family it's over
400 pounds in vat this year alone on top
of national insurance on top of freezing
uh income tax allowance that's why we
think the conservatives just lost the
plot they are piling on these unfair tax
risers time and again when people are
struggling with uh with their bills yeah
but the chance i mean the chancellor was
a hero wasn't he during the pandemic he
managed to keep so many people still
being paid week after week after week
under the furlough scheme he's got to
pay for it somehow well liberal
democrats supported the furlough scheme
and that's right and let's have
cross-party agreement where we can
however we've got to look at fair ways
of raising the money that we need so
liberal democrats were the first party
to argue for a windfall tax on the
soaring profits of the oil and gas
companies it's just wrong that they're
profiteering so much from this rise in
oil and gas prices which is hitting
businesses and of course hitting
families and pensioners across the uk so
the democrats want a fairer system where
we tax the profits the with the windfall
tax of the oil and gas companies and use
that to cut taxes on on families um on
monday i think it was yeah monday uh the
world secretary sat exactly where you
are now simon hearts and he told us that
the world has moved on from partygate
has it
i don't think so
um i've been going up and down the
country talking to people ahead of the
local elections i was in whole other
week somerset the week before so around
the country and it's something that the
ordinary people are bringing up
unprompted
i think they feel that um boris johnson
is not a decent prime minister that he's
broken uh the law uh that he's lied to
parliament and they expect more from a
prime minister and what's really
staggering is lifelong conservative
voters uh don't think he's a decent
prime minister that's what we found in
cheshire amisham when we beat the
conservatives liberal democrats beat the
conservatives in true blue
buckinghamshire what we found in north
shropshire a seat held by the
conservatives for 200 years liberal
democrats beat them and part of the
reason that another reason was ambulance
waiting times and the awful deal for
farmers that the government have
concluded but another reason was
lifelong conservatives saying this tory
prime minister boris johnson is not fit
to be prime minister gonna have to
unpack that for you because we don't
know that the prime minister's broken
the law we'll have to wait and see what
the police say he certainly looks as
though he has presided over law breaking
in downing street is that enough for him
uh to step down some might say and also
we've heard from the ukrainian leader
who's praising him to the skies
well let's deal with ukraine because
that's such a critical uh issue uh i'm
actually quite uh in praise of ben
wallace ben is the second secretary yeah
he's the secretary of state for defence
and he's been leading the support for
ukraine uh president elena peter no
doubt is praising johnson the real
person i think we should all praise is
actually ben wallace and here you are me
a liberal democrat praising conservative
minister because i'm trying to be
balanced but boris johnson we've now
begun to see
through him and i was at school in my
conditions the other day and unprompted
these teenage people said sir was it a
party or was it a work event and i said
to them you tell me do you know what
they said it was a party you know people
can see for their own eyes what happened
i think the prime minister should resign
before i think tory mps should have
sacked him for his fate to resign
and frankly whether or not the met
police ultimately give him one of these
notices uh the people in mike's agency
and around the country they've passed
the judgment he's guilty of breaking the
law even if he is and even if he has
mislead parliament we'll have to wait to
see the opposition which includes you
and and the snp and of course labor
doesn't seem to have enough strength to
do anything about it now you'll say to
me that that it has to be uh
to worry about benches that make the
difference but there has to be some
strong arm tactics from the opposition
as well and just doesn't seem to be
there yeah but your viewers have got
some power in this they've got to say
your viewers if they send a message at
the ballot box in the local elections i
would argue by electing strong local
liberal democrat champions in the local
council sends a really powerful message
they can help get rid of boris johnson
so your viewers i really want to tell
them this
tell the conservative party tell boris
johnson tell conservative mps that he
has to go and if they don't will you eat
your words
well um i think from the one people i've
spoken to they want to do that
we should we saw that they did that in
cheshire we saw they did that in north
shropshire where liberal democrats beat
uh conservatives and no one expected us
to and my feeling from the doorsteps is
that the voters want this prime minister
to go they don't think he's decent they
don't think he's fair and the way he and
rishi sunap the chancellor have
responded to the cost of living crisis
is frankly a scandal they either don't
seem to care they don't get it and
they're doing absolutely nothing and
that's not acceptable
if they don't if my loyal viewers do not
vote against the prime minister do you
have to acknowledge that we've moved on
from partygate well i don't like
predicting what the voters are going to
do before they have done it so let's
wait to see certainly the evidence is
they are very unhappy with the prime
minister rightly not just for partygate
but for the way he's been running the
country um and let's see i mean i'm
pretty uh optimistic i think if you go
around the country you know i was uh in
harrogate the other day i'm going
wimbledon today we're picking up in
those little democrat battlegrounds uh
that people want to send the government
a message and and i can't blame them
given how badly they've handled both
party gate and the cost of living lots
of labour politicians who've been
sitting where you are um have said to me
that they want richie soon actually go
for partygate just indiscretions as well
what do you think
well um the evidence on him is less than
the prime minister the evidence against
the prime minister i think is
overwhelming um there is certainly
evidence against the chancellor um i i
probably haven't viewed that as
carefully as i should i i think the
chance that the law sure the chance that
the chancellor certainly has a lot of
questions to answer over particularly
that is absolutely if he's broken the
law should he if he's breaking the law
should go of course and if he's broken
that way if he gets a fixed penalty
notice he's broken the law yeah and he
would get a fixed penalty notice if he
was in the cabinet room when there was
cake
listen see where i'm going with this
yeah yeah yeah well i mean i i i think
you're right to go there i think you're
right i mean people expect your viewers
expect
politicians who set the rules that they
should keep the rules there's not one
rule for them and another rule for the
rest of us that is just unfair it's not
british it's not the tradition of our
great country
and if boris johnson and rishi sunaka
are trouncing the rule of law and
trouncing british traditions that is not
acceptable and they should go okay
unfortunately i'd love to talk to you
for longer but we're out of time so
we're going to have to leave it there
thank you very much